maki catta une histoire de laurence
coulombier
illustré par modeste madoré aux éditions
océan jeunesse
c'était à madagascar
grande île de l'océan indien dans le
massif de l'isalo
maquis un sacrés lascars faisait la joie
et le désespoir de ses parents
avec son masque de zorro serti de ses
yeux ronds exorbités ses petites mains
aux doigts agiles ses oreilles
parabolique et sa queue serpentine
dressé en point d'interrogation à
rayures maquis cumuler les âneries
qu'un âne face des âneries
soit mais un maquis
papa et maman lémuriens trouvé cela un
poil vexant
maquis et met ainsi entre autres
pitreries sauter de branche en branche
avec une belle énergie ce qui manque est
rarement de faire tomber les couples
affairés à s'épouiller ou à se
papouiller
ne peut en plus c'est pouilles et où se
papouiller en paix se plaignaient les
époux chu
maquis moquer souvent les oreilles
minuscule de ses cousins sifaka
deux petits points noirs enfouis dans
leur pelage beige et touffu pas peu fier
de ses grandes oreilles il les laisser
traîner partout
il écoutait autres on surprenait les
conversations et révéler les secrets les
plus intimes
bref il portait bien son double prénom
de maki catta
son papa et sa maman hurler des aot car
il ya
d'impuissance en s'arrachant les poils
de rage
chez les lémuriens la maman a autant de
poils que le papa et ne se les arrachent
que lorsqu'elle est vraiment en colère
d'ordinaire elles portent le plus grand
soin au lustre de son pelage qu'elle
entretient par des bonnes soleil et un
régime de bananes
nos fêtes vous avait déjà présenté les
parents de maquis
ouais
la ressemblance n'est pas frappante
c'est que notre petit singe n'a pas
toujours été le roi des singeries avant
de venir agiter sa queue et bray sous le
nez des sifaka de l'isalo maquis naquit
à ranomafana
là un terrible incendie dévaste à le
coin de la forêt au ses parents sa
petite soeur et lui étaient installés
les feuilles de bambou avait flambé en
moins de temps qu'il n'en faut pour un
maquis de volée de branche en branche
son père et sa mère lui avait crié sauf
toi ne regarde pas en arrière avant
d'avoir rejoint la vallée
haletant
essoufflé par sa course folle tu m'as
qui s'était finalement retourné
il avait observé le méchant feu lécher
les troncs des arbres jusqu'à la sève
il avait scruté cet horizon de malheur
des heures durant
il avait assisté au spectacle de l'exode
des caméléons des roussettes d à peu les
murs fuyant le désastre
lorsque les palissandre vaincu furent
réduits en cendres ni le papa ni la
maman
ni la petite soeur de makeen était
réapparu seul
perdu
à l'orée de la forêt sans arbre il
fixait de ses gros yeux ronds humide
cette terre qui l'avait vu naître
sa splendide que noire et blanche
qu'il brandissait toujours fièrement
vers le ciel
trenet piteusement derrière lui sur le
sol de la vallée des larmes
la mort dans l'âme il avait rejoint les
massifs les plus arides de l'isalo où
les rochers ne craignait pas le feu
il y avait trouvé refuge auprès des
lémuriens de tous poils à grandes
oreilles à petites oreilles tous
bicolore mais tous unis
parmi eux un couple qui n'avait pas
d'enfant faca et six femmes s'étaient
approchés et s'était émue de l'histoire
de l'enfant qui n'avait plus de parents
il l'avait regardé il s'était regardé il
l'avait aimé tout de suite
inconditionnellement
maki catta avait trouvé une seconde
famille un papa faca et une maman sifa
bien décidé à déverser sur lui des flots
d'amour à étouffer tous les incendies de
toutes les forêts
mais certains feux en apparence et un
nourrissent des braises qui n'en
finissent pas de brûler
la nouvelle existence de maquis ne
parvenait pas à lui faire oublier
l'ancien certes faca et six femmes ne
ménageait pas leur joie pour lui rendre
le goût de vivre
mais les seules joies de maka était de
faire choir les ai poussés pouilles en
surprendre les conversations et raillé
les oreilles de ses cousins
maquis ne pouvait s'empêcher de rappeler
à tous qu'ils n'étaient pas des leurs
il était jolie comme un coeur mais aussi
avenant qu un intestin grêle de quoi ses
parents se faire de la bile
fac à notre mât qui m'inquiète
je t'écoute
aimes-tu sept enfants et bien sûr
quelques questions non je veux dire pas
comme cet enfant
comme ton fils
je laime sifa il est mon fils je
dissèque les bambous pour le nourrir
j'écume les arbres avec lui pour le
faire grandir je tremble quand il à la
truffe sèche je frémis quand il pose ses
petits doigts au creux de ma grosse
patte
lorsqu'il nous prend pour cibles le
penser friponnerie
derrière mon front français je ris je le
couve des yeux j'ai la pâte prête à
bondir silva 6 et le coeur qui chavire
dès qu il bondit vers moi il est mon
fils je laime si fort
je sais nous le portons en nous mais
nous ne l'avons pas mieux au monde je
voudrais tant qu'ils comprennent que
nous avons choisi de lier notre destin
aux siens pour toujours
qu'il appartient à la bambouseraie de
l'isalo au même titre que ses cousins
qu'il est autant ton fils que ses
cousins sont les fils de ta soeur et par
dessus tout qu aucun incendie ne viendra
troubler la paix de notre canyon
maquis
surprenez des conversations
il surpris la prière de sa mère
cette prière le surpris
quel secret allait-il cette fois révélé
le sien
celui qui s'était enfui dans son coeur
en ce jour noir où il avait fui la forêt
dévastée de ranomafana
le secret de ne plus faire confiance à
ses parents de ne plus attachés à rien
de ne plus se rendre aimable pour ne
plus risquer d'être aimé
de ne laisser aucune prise aux flammes
pourtant lui aussi aimé déposer ses
petits doigts dans la pâte ferme de
fakka il aimait abandonné sa tête sur la
poitrine velue de cif à
lui revint alors en mémoire les
dernières paroles d'amour de ses parents
de ranomafana
sauve toi ne regarde pas en arrière
avant d'avoir rejoint la vallée pour
se sauver il ne faut pas regarder en
arrière
il pensa aussi à sa petite soeur si le
coeur d'une maman est assez grand pour
et mes deux enfants pourquoi le coeur
d'un enfant ne pourrait-il pas et mes
deux mamans
mac y avait une promesse à tenir
cette terre de l'isalo il l'avait promis
à ses parents disparus
il fallait empoigné à pleine pâte cette
nouvelle vallée de l'amour une nouvelle
terre une nouvelle mère un nouveau père
et pour la seconde fois na kim acquis
sa fourrure grise son museau allongé ses
oreilles sans pareil ça que bicolore il
portait fièrement ses origines
cependant lorsqu'il regardait à présent
si fa efa qu'à leur pelage marron et
beige leurs têtes rondes leurs oreilles
microscopique leur que unis il se
reconnaissait en eux il était son
devenir ils avaient été rassemblés par
hasard et une désormais ils se
ressemblaient par amour
ma qui dès lors ne cherche à plus de
poids personnes en revanche ils les
pouilles et et papouiller père mère
cousins tantes et tout y maquille les
sifaka quant à eux fait taire l'heureux
événement par des danses épileptique et
des sceaux extatique debout bras écartés
le sol sous leurs pattes à ressort et
est devenu un vaste trampoline
certains toutefois entrepris en une
célébration plus paisible à six
bras écartés
il offrait au chaleureux soleil tropical
leurs torses soyeux
c'est ainsi que l'orphelin de ranomafana
le coeurs brûlés mais ressuscité
adopte à ses parents de l'isalo